My pieces are littered with book recommendations,..
...but I want this to be different.
I want to spark that same excitement and joy...
...that I feel when I'm consuming a book, in you.
So I'm gonna make this kind of like a visual and auditory experience.
I want to share what I felt...
...when I was listening to four books in particular.
Here we go.
"Sapiens"
This book is a masterpiece.
Nothing I've ever read has so greatly shifted my perspective on humanity.
Listening to the sweeping prose...
...on the origins and evolution of our race on this earth...
...felt like I left my body and floated above the clouds.
From there, I watched thousands of years unfold.
As our ancestors experienced all of the evolving wonders and horrors...
...of what it meant to be a human.
Something about this book just made things click for me.
How and why we operate and interact the way that we do.
The origins of tribalism, religion, and money,...
...and how these things exist in our world today.
I find these insights useful in my day-to-day life, actually.
They kind of inform many of my decisions,...
...and how I interpret what occurs around me.